فتحت مراكز الاقتراح في الساحل الشرقي
الامريكي ابوابها امام الناخبين للادلاء
باصواتهم في انتخابات التجديد النصفي
بالكونغرس وقد صوت اكثر من 41 مليون شخص
بشكل مبكر في سبع واربعين ولعب
وشهدت عمليه التصويت رفع حوالين 120 قضيه
قانونيه اعتبارا من الثالث من نوفمبر
يتعلق معظمها بتقييد الوصول الى الاقتراع
ففي ولايه بنسلفانيا تحث بعض المقاطعه
الناخبين على تصحيح بطاقات الاقتراع
الغيابيه ذات التواريخ المفقوده او غير
الصحيحه التي امرت المحكمه العليا في
الولايه بالغائنا فيما رفض قاض في متشجن
دعوه قضائيه قدمها مرشح جمهوري بهدف الغاء
الاقتراع الغيابي
هذا وقد مددت مقاطعه كام في جورجيا موعد
التسليم النهائي لنحو 1000 بطاقه اقتراع
غيابين حتى الرابع عشر من نوفمبر نظرا
لتاخر ارسال بطاقات الاقتراع في البريد
اما في اريزونا فارسل وزير خارجيه الولايه
ثماني 10 احاله لتطبيق القانون تتعلق
بالترهيب بما في ذلك رساله تهديد لموظف
حكومي والعديد من النابي